[Music]
I mean fear to say that is one of the
defining songs of the 90s and let's not
forget that no other American girl group
has sold more records than TLC so I was
like a giddy little kid when the ladies
invited me to creep on set of their new
music video even after all the years the
struggles and the heartbreak Chilean
t-boz are still crazysexycool
and the love for TLC is still strong
[Music]
stick to you sue how does that make you
feel when you turn it on you see there's
TLC news I don't honestly I started
grilled cheesus do you like big turbo
sets of teeth okay it's all day yeah
leaving yourself the rest is up to the
media Joo The Voice coaches version has
been viewed more than 62 million times
TLC also performed it on Dancing with
the Stars but can you believe it's been
22 years since waterfalls first became a
hit we were on set of that music video
back in 1995 Tionne t-boz Watkins is now
a mom of two including almost two year
old adopted son chance Rozonda chilli
Thomas has a 20 year old son of her own
Lisa left eye Lopes died in a car crash
in 2002 but the ladies keep her spirit
alive in their music their name and
their fashion look at every one of them
yeah yeah she's always with she's on oh
she's on YouTube fans always tell us how
they can fill her energy because even
with like ain't appropriate fun dated in
the morning you know everyone ain't too
proud to beg no
[Music]
t-boz and chilly still have plenty of
swag I witnessed it as they shot their
new music video way back yeah
TLC's got a whole new generation of fans
look out in the audience and we see you
know like 10 year olds and stuff in I'm
not lying when it's time to sing red
light special and the kids are right
there yeah the gyrating kind of slows
down a little bit
cuz back in the day we booked Green
Knight you know yeah all their gyration
every night thinking about it like that
did t-boz told me she's doing fine after
having a brain tumor removed 11 years
ago and watch how I sneak in this
question to Chile about those Nick
Cannon dating rumors I really do love
Nick and I thought that y'all were gonna
be I thought the Navy yeah I hope I had
hope I know Nick is my god peel the blue
that's and I was like oh we're just
friends okay TLC has a lot of celebrity
friends including Katy Perry who donated
$5,000 to the band's Kickstarter
campaign funding their new self-titled
album TLC Katy wanna sleep over so what
was that like hanging okay well honestly
we have nothing
oh no not yet when you see ya where are
you girl we have our onesies been
waiting yeah one is I had so much fun
with the ladies and maybe they'll
squeeze in that sleepover with Katy
while they're out on tour the ladies hit
the road as part of the I love the 90s
tour starting July 7th meanwhile the new
album will be available June 30th
[Music]